let's see if we can build a bit on some
of our work with linear transformations
let's say i have two linear
transformations to have the
transformation s that's a
mapping or a function from
the set x to the set
y
and let's just say that x is a subset of
let me write it here x is a subset of r
n and let's say that y
is a subset of r
m of r m then we know if s is a linear
transformation it can be represented by
a matrix vector product so we can
write s of x
let me do it in the same color i was
doing it before
we can write that s
of some vector x is equal to some matrix
a
times x and the matrix a it's going to
be
x whatever x we input into the function
though we take the mapping of it's going
to be in this set right here it's going
to be a member of our n so this is going
to be
right here x is let me do it like this
x is going to be a member of r
n so what's actually going to be a
member of x which is a subset of r n but
i'm just trying to figure out what the
dimensions of matrix a are going to be
so this is going to have n components
right here matrix a has to have n
columns so matrix a is going to be let's
just say it's an m by n matrix
m
by end fair enough now let's say we have
another
linear transformation so actually let me
draw what i've said what i've done so
far so we have some set x right here
that is set x it is a subset of
r
n r n i could draw out there and we have
this mapping s or this linear
transformation from x to y so it goes to
a new set
y right here
goes to a new set
y
and y is a member of rm so the mapping
the mapping
x right
here the mapping x
you take some element here and you apply
the transformation s and i've told you
it's a linear transformation and you'll
get to some value in
set y which is an rm and i said that the
matrix representation of our linear
transformation is going to be an m by n
matrix right because you're going to
start with something that has n entries
or a vector that's a member of rn and
you want to end up with a vector that's
in rm fair enough now let's say i have
another linear transformation t
i have another linear transformation t
and it's a mapping from the set y
to the set
z so let me draw
so i have
i have
another set here called set
z
and i can map from elements of y so i
could map from here
into elements of z using the linear
transformation t
so let's similar what i did before we
know that y is a member of r m we know
that this is a subset not a member more
of a subset of rm and i'm you know these
are just arbitrary letters this could be
100 or 5 or whatever i'm just trying to
stay
abstract and let's say that z is a
member
i'm running out of letters let's say z
is a member of r
z is a member of r
l
then what's the transformation t what's
its matrix representation going to be
and we know it's a linear transformation
i told you that so we know it can be
represented in this form so we could say
that t
of x
where x is a member of r m
where x is a member of rm is going to be
equal to some matrix b
times x
and what are the dimensions of matrix b
going to be
x is going to be a member of r m
so b is going to have to have m columns
and then it's a mapping into a set
that's a member of rl so it's going to
map from members of rm to members of rl
so it's going to be an l
by m matrix right there now when you see
this a a very natural question might
arise in your head can we construct some
mapping
that goes all the way
that goes all the way from set x
all the way to set t
and maybe we'll call that let me call
that the composition of and maybe we can
create that mapping using a combination
of s and t
so let's call
let's just make up some word let's just
call t
with this little circle s
let's just call this
a mapping from x all the way to z
from x all the way to z
and we'll call this the composition
the composition
composition
of
t
with s we're essentially just combining
the two functions in order to try to
create some mapping that takes us from t
from set x
all the way to set z but we still
haven't defined this how can we actually
construct this well a natural thing
might be
to first apply
transformation s let's say that this is
our x we're dealing with right here
maybe the first thing we want to do is
apply s
and that will give us
an s of x
that will give us this value right here
that's in set y
and then what if we were to take that
value and apply the transformation t to
it
so we would apply take this value and
apply the transformation t to it to
maybe get to this value
so this would be the linear
transformation t applied to this value
this this member of our y of of of the
set y which is an rm
so we're just going to apply that
transformation to this guy right here
which was the transformation s applied
to x
this might look fancy but all this is
remember this is just a vector right
here in the set y which is a subset of r
m this is a vector that's in x so when
you apply a mapping you get another
vector that's in y and then you apply
the mat the linear transformation t to
that and then you get another vector
that's in set z so let's define
the composition of t with s so this is
going to be a definition
let's define the composition of t with s
to b
first we apply s to some vector in x
so we apply s to some vector in x to get
us here and then we apply t to that
vector to get us to set z
to get us to set so we apply t
to this thing right there
now the first question might be is this
even a linear transformation
is the composition of two linear
transformations even a linear
transformation
is it a linear
linear transformation
well there are two requirements to be a
linear transformation right the sum of
the linear transformation of the sum of
two vectors should be the linear
transformation of each of them summed
together so let's see when i know when i
just say that verbally it probably
doesn't make a lot of sense so let's
just try to take the composition
the composition of t
with s
of
let's say the sum of two vectors in x so
let's say i'm taking the vectors
x
and
the vectors y well by definition what is
this equal to this is equal to
this is equal to applying the linear
transformation t
to the linear transformation s
applied to our two vectors
x
plus y
and what is this equal to i told you at
the beginning of the video that s is a
linear transformation so by definition
of a linear transformation one of our
requirements we know that s of x plus y
is the same thing as
s
of x
plus
s
of y because s is a linear
transformation we know that that is true
we know that we can replace
this thing right there with that thing
right there well we also know that t is
a linear transformation which means that
the transformation applied to the sum of
two vectors is equal to the
transformation
of each of the vectors summed up so the
transformation of s
of x
or the transformation applied to the
transformation of s applied to x i know
the terminology is getting confused plus
t
of
s of y
this is we can do this because we know
that t is a linear transformation but
what is this right here this is equal to
all this statement right here is equal
to the composition of t
with s
applied to x
plus the composition of t with s applied
to y
so given that both t and s are linear
transformations we got our first
requirement that the composition of
applied to the sum of two vectors is
equal to the composition applied to each
of the vectors summed up so that was our
first
requirement for a linear transformation
and then our second one is we need to
apply this to a scalar multiple of of a
vector in x so t
of s or let me say this way the
composition of t with s applied to some
scalar multiple
of some vector x that's in our set x
this is a vector x that's our set x this
should be a capital x
this is equal to what
well by our definition of our linear of
our of our composition this is equal to
the transformation t
applied to
the transformation s applied to
c times our vector x
and what is this equal to we know that
this is a linear transformation so given
that this is a linear transformation
that s is a linear transformation we
know that this can be rewritten as t
times
c
times s applied to x
this little replacing that i did with s
applied to c times x is the same thing
as c times the linear transformation
applied to x this just comes out of the
fact that s is a linear transformation
we've done that multiple times well now
we have t applied to some scalar
multiple of some vector and so we can do
the same thing we know that t is a
linear transformation so we know that
this is equal to i'll do it down here
this is equal to c times t
applied to s applied to some
vector x that's in there and what is
this equal to
this is equal to
the constant c
times the composition t with s
of our vector x right there so we've met
our second requirement for a linear
transformation
so the composition as we've defined it
is definitely a linear transformation
now that means that this thing right
here can be written
this means that
the composition of t with s can be
written as some
matrix let me write it this way the
composition of t with s applied to or
the transformation of the which is the
composition of t with s applied to some
vector x
can be written
as some
matrix
times
our vector x and what will be the
dimensions of our matrix we're going
from a
n dimension space so this is going to
have n columns
to a l dimensions base so this is going
to have l rows so it's going to be an l
by n matrix
now i'll leave you there in this video
because i realize i've been making too
many 20 minute plus videos in the next
video now that we know this is a linear
transformation and then we know that we
can represent it as a matrix vector
product we'll actually figure out how to
represent this matrix
especially in relation to the two
matrices that define our transformations
s and t